si no tenemos resultados definitivos
Esperamos que los vayamos a tener en
las siguientes horas incluso minutos lo
que sí que tenemos es un final que
muchos esperaban que es que
tal como está yendo el conteo de votos
lo más probable es que estas elecciones
turcas se decidan en una segunda vuelta
ahora mismo erdogan ya está por debajo
del 50% en el apoyo popular por su parte
que malcharolo estaría alrededor del 45%
Y a medida que estos votos se van
contabilizando erdogan baja más Mientras
que el opositor que mal que va subiendo
más por lo tanto Xbox populi que estas
elecciones se decidirán el día 28 de
mayo aquí en Turquía por lo tanto
no están habiendo realmente
celebraciones en la calle porque todo el
mundo sabe que hoy simplemente se ha
producido un paso más hacia un final que
llegará como decíamos a finales de mayo
Albert estamos pendientes de que este
10% pues acaba de definir una tendencia
o de la vuelta a estos resultados Que
recordemos de momento están con el 90%
de los votos escrutados le pregunto cómo
es que ha habido este este giro en
digamos las tendencias a lo largo del
día es que las ciudades se han tardado
más en escrutar Cómo ha sido este conteo
tan lento
y bueno nos informaban
personas de que estaban en los Colegios
electorales que muchos interventores del
partido de la justicia y del desarrollo
de resetta y perdón impugnaban ciertos
resultados opositores por lo que no se
contabilizaban o han tardado más en
contabilizarse estos votos por lo tanto
al llegar un poquito más tarde que los
votos de
erdogan al final más o menos al final de
la noche han ido equiparándose los
resultados tal como decían las agencias
privadas que la diferencia entre ambos
candidatos sería de uno o dos puntos
ahora Estamos viendo que la agencia
gubernamental ya empieza a mostrar unos
resultados donde erdogan efectivamente
iría a una siguiente vuelta a una
segunda vuelta con qué mal
y Albert usted que conoce como es la
noche ahí en Estambul Cómo cómo siente
que es particularmente está velada ahí
en la ciudad turca es decir Usted dice
ya se espera lo que parece de momento
que va a pasar que es una eventual
segunda vuelta Aunque recordemos a él no
lo estamos todavía confirmando sin
embargo la gente está pendiente de estos
últimos minutos de conteo
sí totalmente es decir cada voto cuenta
todo el mundo está en sus casas
pendientes y como bien has dicho esto no
es un resultado definitivo pero
oficialmente con el 90% casi del
escrutinio realizado es muy probable que
esta segunda vuelta se produzca aquí en
Estambul como como digo no están
habiendo grandes fiestas en Las Plazas
ni en las calles porque no es un
resultado definitivo todo el mundo sabe
que a partir del 28 de mayo se podrá
saber quién será el siguiente presidente
de Turquía esta noche en ningún caso se
va a saber